bra bra bra perfetto per tutti ragazzi e
benvenuti questo video sono fa vj non so
se vi ricordate di me e c l'aci oggi
proveremo a vedere se gli meis sanno
qualcosa gli fa vj se sbagliate ma io
non ci facciamo il test funziona
ragazzi se sbagliamo un lumacone a testa
mentre le due e 1 andiamo a fare ma
allora la partita e doppiatore aspetta
va bene
ratchet clank ma non va ha sbagliato
breve fuga fatto quali j per spiegare i
fan che cosa voleva dire il suo
tatuaggio non so io aspetta a leggere
contenere ha fatto un 2006 fatto proprio
niente lo spiato subito fatto sui miei
fan quando ha fatto una duna reggio
calabria 28 ne scuso io no ad esclusione
fermo [ __ ] di fede non perché allora
aspetta 28 ottobre 7 29 mar 5 agosto a
reggio calabria il 9 marzo marzo marc
marquez
69 stagione ma cos'è successo
no no sociale
con la [ __ ] che vederci [ __ ] va
bene rossi ma domani dobbiamo mangiare
il balcone starò un video semplice delle
mani da solo
io non la volevo fare la penitenza per
loro hanno scelto loro di volerla fare
non so perché orientamenti ballo vi fate
capire perché da qui dove mai possono
stare vicine si buttano addosso ma ci
possono stare vicino a saldo qual è la
serie principale sui dati guidate al 100
e più il principale però anche da un po
pro non è principali buyout umanità e
non è ancora mai stai stupro continuerei
aveva detto milanese prezzi verso le gae
dentro l'anima tenere la francia che
nella barca mammamia troppo aspetta
campani giravolte in un blog ha ricevuto
un palco detto c'è una torta chi
gliel'ha sbattuta in faccia il re cos'è
r reale passi cosa dice fa vi sono nella
vasca eccesso dopo fa
[Applauso]
però se si voleva subito 100.000 like
così americani aspetti diretta nuovo
problema però [ __ ] dall'estero la
conosceva mi ha insegnato alla vigilia
100 maschi ti ho incontrato i tagli su
2013 aveva ancora capito io non l'ho mai
e poi sono diventati famosi kv ceo si
chiama lorenzo si chiama antonio questo
non lo dovevi dire cosa vietata mela
scrive farsi spedire a casa il fa di
ventilatore o tanto caldo christope
caldo sul meno di casa dolcifica ritardo
a caso noi aias pensa prima di parlare
di per sé anche obbligati mangiare in
famiglia aspetta senti sergio era il 20
era un dente cosa si faceva nel video
chi ha fatto di recente concreta menchi
è ormai mai le caramelle da lamelle ma
lei era messa male ma forse la vita
peraltro dopo averlo visto file j con
chi hai dato i ragazzi spagna agosto
i suoi genitori e la sua migliore amica
visto letto dopo instagram
come si chiama la madre di favi gen
orbene bella che domanda seria
finalmente ora faccio il suo numero è
stato marcia questo telo magistero loria
ma l'amore che ford era tutta l'arcata
di sopra non la voglio più come inizi
sui viva per l'ultima bella tematica
cara video l'ultima l'ultimo a carico io
voglio solo io se giustamente dove si
trovava boom milano stagno tumulato nel
vedermi tomorrow tumori di milano
la skin una sera metti a questo punto
l'ho fatto a un mio fan a lorenzo
nessuno azzecca così tante anch'io
quando va bene ragazzi dire che questo
video fatto un terminale può terminare
qui questo va bene ragazzi spero che vi
sia piaciuto ringraziamento per hyper
chip ati questo video che il comandante
rivale per il telecomando
ma dove siamo messi che per chiudere noi
è un telecomando ma se è piaciuta non si
dica ho lasciato il commento è un mi
piace ai capace di facebook e coloni
adottata descrizione se avessi i
fischiatori ci vediamo il prossimo video
e da ragazzi io risponderò alle domande
sui mail che mi ha detto papà palazzotto
incollato fuori ragazzini domenica ho
detto va bene